[Música]
ah
en la actualidad la inflación en
argentina está por encima del 50% anual
según cifras oficiales el aumento de los
precios tiene un impacto directo sobre
la vida cotidiana de los argentinos hoy
por ejemplo el alquiler mensual promedio
de un departamento con una habitación y
una sala en la ciudad de buenos aires es
de unos 415 dólares al cambio oficial
según el sitio osana prop pero el
salario mínimo en argentina es tan lejos
de ese número equivale a unos 290
dólares
la frase repetida aquí es que los
precios suben por ascensor pero los
sueldos lo hacen por escalera desde 2018
el poder adquisitivo del salario cayó un
11 por ciento según un cálculo de la
fundación mediterránea un centro de
estudios y otro el instituto para el
desarrollo social argentino estimó que
en el sector informal esa caída fue el
triple en el país el aumento de precios
es un problema persistente que se ha
agudizado en años recientes desde 2014
la inflación en argentina no baja del
24% anual
[Música]
el iván afronta una de las crisis
financieras más severas en el mundo
desde 1850 según el banco mundial la
acelerada caída de la moneda local que
ha perdido más del 90% de su valor y la
fuerte infracción que alcanzan los tres
dígitos ha conducido al país a una
catástrofe humanitaria más del 50% de la
población vive hoy bajo el umbral de la
pobreza y un 30 en extrema pobreza a
nivel general podríamos decir que la
vida se ha encarecido en un 400 por
ciento con respecto a 2019 el litro de
leche costaba 3.000 libras y ahora
cuesta 22 mil el aceite para cocinar es
ahora 37 veces más caro que en 2019 y
una caja de analgésicos comunes cuesta 5
veces más los precios de los productos
subsidiados como el pan y la gasolina
también han aumentado y sin embargo los
sueldos se mantienen igual lo que hace
que sea casi imposible para la gente
común poder pagar los bienes básicos
i
venezuela registró en los cinco primeros
meses de este año una inflación
acumulada de 260 y 4.8 por ciento según
el dato más reciente del banco central
de venezuela que suele retrasar las
publicaciones de sus reportes económicos
este país se encuentra en su cuarto año
de hiperinflación y su séptimo de
recesión con una dolarización
transaccional que comenzó en 2019 en
venezuela hay una galopante variación de
precios pues el valor del bolívar a la
moneda local se ha pulverizado tanto que
es mucho más fácil ver en las calles y
en los comercios billetes de dólares
antes que el propio bolívar incluso la
mayoría de los bienes se marcan ya en
moneda extranjera una situación bastante
difícil para la mayoría de los
venezolanos con un poder adquisitivo
diluido por la inflación las personas
por ejemplo que trabajan en el sector
público reciben un salario mínimo
oficial equivalente a menos de 4 dólares
mensuales mientras que en el sector
privado el sueldo puede rondar los 90
dólares también insuficiente en este
país
[Música]